so you're in the market to take over a
country to liberate its people and to
exploit its natural resources steal its
money or just to earn the title of the
world's newest dictator there are a lot
of benefits that come from launching a
coup d'etat and you're not alone for
decades global superpowers like the us
have gone crazy with coups and rigged
elections to get the people they wanted
in power in the 42 years of the cold war
from 1947 to 1989 america was involved
in at least 70 attempts to overthrow
governments that is almost two a year
and the organization tasked with
carrying out these operations our good
friends at the cia they were so obsessed
with overthrowing governments that they
even released books like the manual for
psychological operations in guerilla
warfare and the cia manual for trickery
and deception
that way their agents can learn the best
way to get their unwanted leader out and
the dictator of the day in
sure these queues often created worse
leaders but it was for the good of
america so it was worth it right which
brings us to you our future dictator in
chief if the cia in america could carry
out all these coups and still be seen as
the moral standard of the world why
can't you
you want what's best for people right
and if you get filthy rich and drunk on
power in the process well that's just an
added benefits welcome to the simple
guide to overthrowing your governments
thank you to the cia for sponsoring this
video
i'm kidding i'm kidding roll the intro
[Music]
mobsters billionaire businessmen and the
people who watch this channel all have
one thing in common they need to smell
good to leave a good first impression
that's because a good first impression
can make or break a business deal a
potential girlfriend etc no one wants to
be with a scrub what you might not know
is that one of the best tricks to
smelling like the best version of
yourself is your laundry detergent that
is where laundry sauce comes in laundry
sauce is the world's best smelling
detergent for men that come in these
convenient easy to use paws that are
shipped straight to your home here's how
it works you choose from either the warm
and rich australian sandalwood or the
crisp and clean siberian pine as your
scent it gets shipped straight to your
door and all you have to do is load up
your washer throw in a pod and that is
it laundry sauce is made from high-end
exotic ingredients like indonesian
patchouli and juniper berry to create
bold and long lasting scents plus their
secret sauce is gentle on your clothing
works in all washing machines and
doesn't have any phosphates or parabens
in it it only takes one laundry saucepot
to get all your clothes clean and
smelling good and with 69 diet free pods
per box that means you're only paying
one dollar per load so if you want to
smell better and have more confidence
pause the video and head to
laundrysauce.com jaytram with the link
below and get your first box of luxury
laundry paws today that's
laundrysauce.com jaytram with the link
below thanks to laundry sauce for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
your first step as a soon-to-be world
leader is to choose your country your
best option is probably going to be your
home country or at least one you have
citizenship in you want to make your
leadership look legitimate so you have
to be a man of the people to get popular
supports but that is not the only way to
overthrow a government none of the cia's
coups took place in the us for obvious
reasons they would go into another
country create instability overthrow the
governments and replace it with their
own group of puppets people that they
could control without it looking like
the us was in charge and you can do the
exact same thing
first you want to choose a country with
a weak political system a lot of
infighting people protesting in the
streets or one without a lot of friendly
neighbors and you also want to make sure
it's rich in natural resources like gold
or oil or the location has a strategic
geopolitical advantage you are in this
for the money and power after all and
finally make sure the country you choose
has an easily corruptable military
because the military is going to be the
one doing the dirty work of taking over
the country for you so a country where
the military and government are often at
odds is usually ripe for a coup
most soldiers care more about their
paycheck than where the money is coming
from anyways especially when the country
doesn't have a strong national identity
as long as you maintain the salary
status quo they really won't care who
they're working for
the cia's most successful queues in
countries like iran guatemala and
nicaragua all relied on getting the
military to side with them early on the
goal is to come into the country as a
knight in shining armor claim that
you're there to liberate the people from
oppression corruption communism whatever
the word of the day is and that's the
angle you're gonna take next
[Music]
once you've picked the country you're
gonna need an inside man this is going
to be the guy who drums up public and
military supports you're propagandist if
you can find a high level military
officer who's also charming or at least
likable and open to guidance on how to
run a country you have struck gold now
you could also find two separate leaders
one to get support from the military and
another to be the face of the revolution
but for the sake of keeping things
simple try to find someone who can do
both and if you can't find the right guy
right away you can always replace the
military officer later on in the iran
coup the cia used general zahidi and
then blindsided him at the last minute
by replacing him with the old shot of
iran in guatemala they used a colonel
named carlos diaz they promised him
control of the country and when the coup
succeeded they replaced him with another
military leader castillo armas not a
great choice of mustache but he was
happy to cooperate with the us so he was
given control of the country
who cares if the inside man you choose
turns into a dictator as long as he does
what you say you can always find a
reason for bringing him into power
[Music]
now that you've found your puppet leader
your next step is to get popular
supports any successful coup will need
the backing of the military the right
politicians and big business if you
choose the right inside man then
military support will follow getting
political support isn't much harder all
you have to do is play on the current
president's bad decisions and suggest
that someone new and more competent
could run the country better most of the
politicians will join you in hopes that
their position and salaries get raised
once the new government takes over
arguably the most important support
you'll need is from the country's big
businesses there are the people who are
going to be paying for a lot of your
coup related expenses in guatemala the
us government worked hand in hand with
the us conglomerates that controlled the
country united fruits the us wanted a
new government and united fruit wanted
less business regulations once you've
convinced the three biggest players to
join your side you're gonna need the
international community to agree with
your coup and by international community
i mean america
[Music]
[Music]
almost every successful qs has some sort
of u.s support or involvement if your
government takeover steps on america's
toes there's a good chance you'll end up
like afghanistan or iraq
[Music]
with decades of war to liberate your
people and install an all-american
puppet instead of the one you chose so
in order to get the world on your side
you'll have to promise america something
oil write a dedicated tax haven a shiny
new base for a cia black site all of
these are great ways to get your new
government started on the right foot
once you have america support the world
will follow all you have to do is throw
around statements like you're bringing
the country into the modern age or that
you're encouraging international
cooperation not only will this drama
political support for what you're about
to do but promising the right kind of
favors could also get a lot of cash
flowing into your coffers ready to be
used for your next steps
up until now your movements have been a
secret every move has been calculated so
that only your team members knows what's
about to go down your next step will be
the most risky psychological warfare or
getting the general population in the
right mindset to support your coup once
this step starts there's a good chance
the standing government will smell a
rats so from now on you'll have to move
very carefully to avoid drawing
attention towards you and your team the
psychological warfare necessary to
overthrow a government is all about
creating chaos and fear people need to
yearn for stability which you will hand
them on a silver platter use your
american friends in the media to
propagate stories of how bad the current
government is accuse the president of
corruption bribery human rights abuses
whatever find incriminating evidence
that top government officials had
affairs stole money sold information to
foreign countries evaded taxes anything
to get the general public fired up with
anger then start the violence encourage
protests against the president to turn
violence make it seem like the
government is telling police to arrest
and injure protesters if the country is
religious get the religious leaders to
speak out against the sitting presidents
do anything it takes to make sure as
many people as possible lose faith in
the current governments this will make
it seem that the coup happened because
of corruption and incompetence not the
other way around once the public hates
the government just enough you're ready
for the final step raising an army
most government takeovers are relatively
peaceful but that's only because the
people throwing the coup have an army so
you're gonna need an army to intimidate
any loyalists who might want to get in
between you and the throne this is where
your inside man in the military and all
that international support comes in
handy getting army units on your side of
the fight should be easy and if you play
your cards right all those international
governments you promise favors to will
be offering you weapons and money to set
your plan in motion in some cases like
america's coup in hawaii or guatemala
the us government may even send in their
own soldiers or equipment to help you
take over as quickly as possible plan
who will be doing what when and where
make sure you have enough men in ammo to
maintain control of key locations like
government buildings ports military
bases and airstrips once you've got your
army ready your plan laid out and the
support of key political figures it is
time to launch your coup d'etat
[Music]
congratulations you've made it to the
moment we've all been waiting for if you
haven't been thrown in jail or killed by
this point your plan is actually likely
to work the tipping point for any
government takeover is in the planning
so making it this far means that you're
just one step away from sweet victory
the best days to stage a coup are always
thursday nights or friday mornings once
you've taken over the government your
main goal will be to return to business
as usual as soon as possible staging a
coup over the weekend means that people
can stay home on friday and then get
back to their normal lives on monday
once you activate your team their first
objective should be to secure the
highest point in governments this means
taking over top level government
buildings and securing the president and
his closest allies while your teams are
closing in on the president other units
should be securing all those strategic
points we talked about earlier a short
internet blackout at this point could
help your men work faster and block
communication between the people who
might oppose you cut off the capital
city with military checkpoints and shows
of power to prevent any opposition and
remind citizens that you are here to
free them from their hated governments
and that everything will go back to
normal as long as they stay home and out
of the streets most coups fail or
succeed within the first few hours if
you manage to keep control of government
buildings military bases and airstrips
for more than 24 hours you're well on
your way to success now the last step is
the regime change announcements this is
where your front man goes out and
reassures all the people that he has
come to bring order and prosperity to
all citizens and that everything would
be so much better with him in charge
than before hold on to power for another
24 hours and by the time monday comes
around you'll be ready to establish your
brand new governments
[Music]
the first week after a coup is probably
more important than anything leading up
to it this is where you appoint your new
political leaders choose a new president
and destroy anyone who might oppose you
once you've created a government that
suits your ambitions it's time to do a
little nation building set up a few new
schools construct some roads kiss a few
babies and rebrand yourself and the
puppet president as men of the people
once you firmly establish your rule
you're ready to suck the nation drive
for all its gods
around the same time the majority of
these liberations were happening the cia
was also drugging and torturing the
american people without their consents
it was in an effort to create what's
called a manchurian candidate a puppet
that could be brainwashed to carry out
assassinations or spy missions without a
moment's hesitation or guilt
it would be like creating a killer robot
with no memory of what it did once the
work was done and all of this human
experimentation was done in the cover of
darkness under the codename mk ultra the
cia secret quest for mind control
drugging and torturing people is
definitely on the edge of what is
monetizable on youtube so i just
released a feature-length 40 minute
documentary on mkultra available only to
members of this channel and if you want
to watch it all you have to do is click
the join button below or click the link
below if you don't see the join button
and you'll get instant access to this
documentary the past one we did on
monsanto and all the future ones we
release every month on how the world
really works and you get all this hidden
knowledge that they would never teach
you in business school for just five
dollars a month and if you join and
don't think it's worth it email me and i
will personally refund you the money
click that join button below to watch
now
[Music]
[Music]
you